[Music]
welcome back you're watching sky news
tonight the top stories this evening and
coveted laws including the requirement
to self-isolate after a positive test
are set to end a month early in england
sky news has spoken to people on the
front line in eastern ukraine about
living with the daily threat of invasion
and ian stewart who was convicted of
killing the children's author helen
bailey has now been found guilty of
murdering his wife six years earlier
well now uh you are watching a a coveted
questions and answer special here on sky
news after the announcement by the prime
minister about an early end to all legal
coveted measures chief among them an end
to the need to self-isolate even after a
positive test the announcement comes of
course at a difficult time for the prime
minister politically leading many to
suspect a political motivation behind
the move but whether you believe that or
not england will be one of the first
western countries to leave restrictions
behind here's the prime minister making
that announcement
provided the current encouraging trends
in the data continue
it is my expectation that we will be
able to end the last domestic
restrictions including the legal
requirement to self-isolate if you test
positive a full month early
[Applause]
and just to remind you how things stand
under the current rules if you test
positive for covert you must
self-isolate for 10 days you can leave
self-isolation early if you take a
lateral flow test on day five and six as
long as both tests are clear the prime
minister will outline his plan for
living with covid when parliament
returns
from its recess on the 21st of february
the legal duty to self-isolate is
expected to be lifted therefore a month
earlier than planned and as long as the
data remains positive the prime minister
said well let's discuss all that putting
your questions to my expert panel i'm
joined now by mark wallhaus professor of
infectious disease epidemiology at the
university of edinburgh chief executive
of the nhs confederation matthew taylor
and clinical nurse specialist at the eve
appeal charity hillary maxwell very good
to have you all here and as i say we've
been um getting a lot of questions sent
in to us here at sky news and uh we've
rolled together
one of the main questions being asked by
nearly everyone that's contacted us
and they're asking what are the signals
here is this the end of the pandemic uh
professor walhaus give us your view
well we've got to leave restrictions
behind us at some stage so the question
is what are the what are the right
trigger points i'm very much in favor of
following data not dates you'll remember
from the lockdown we had early part of
last year 2021
it took an enormous amount of time for
us to start to lift restrictions uh
because people were being very very
cautious about about this
and as a result for example on that
occasion schools they stayed closed for
months even though levels of infections
were low
and there were then fears that when we
relaxed a lot of the restrictions that
we did in july in the summer
that there will be a big wave of
infections and that really didn't
materialize certainly not on the scale
that many people were concerned about
and the public health burden of cobit
remained manageable so i'm optimistic
that that is what will happen on this
occasion too okay matthew taylor from
the nhs perspective the end of the
pandemic well we've seen cases drop
dramatically back in 2020 again in 2021
and then they've gone back up again uh
could it be different this time
well nobody wants another full storm do
they um and yet we would all like to see
life return to normal
so i think we need to hold the prime
minister to his word which is that we
have to wait and see what happens over
the next few weeks the ons data just
today
suggest an infection rate is is going up
but nevertheless the number of people in
hospital which is really the critical
issue for the nhs is for the number of
people in intensive care is falling
but we've got a relatively high
infection rate we still have people
dying from this condition and there is
of course still the danger
of another variant so i think we need to
continue to observe the situation i
don't think we should make this question
a kind of political virility test i
think we should be guided by the public
interest and the other thing is i think
we need to be really clear what we're
saying to the public so even today we've
the government's had to clarify that
whilst the prime minister is hoping to
remove all legal restrictions it will
not be the advice that you should go to
work
if you've got the virus now
we need to be clear about these things
because the one thing we've learned over
the last two years is that if you have
muddled and confusing messages to the
public it doesn't help anyone okay we're
going to get into more of those
specifics
as we continue through these questions
but uh hillary maxwell just that broad
overview from the front line the end of
the pandemic
um well obviously it's always heartening
to see things improving of course but i
think we must remember that um you know
for over two years now uh people who are
vulnerable have been asked to shield and
self-isolate and this has caused huge
anxiety and concern for many many people
and for me who works in cancer care
that's been of considerable concern to
those particular patients and their
families i think what is um important is
about that surety that we're going to
give to those vulnerable people um in
terms of
no need to now self-isolate but for many
people covid has symptoms similar to a
cold and i don't know many of my
colleagues that don't come to work with
a cold but how they're now going to
necessarily know the difference and that
may be of
a huge concern to those people who are
coming to chemotherapy appointments
radiotherapy appointments uh
immunotherapy appointments so i think it
is it is an obligation that we must try
and provide some uh reassurance to to
those people who are vulnerable
and then this uh question thank you all
for those opening comments now the
specific questions and this from tracy
and i'm going to add into it a question
that you've all touched on as well tracy
wants to know what the scientific
evidence
is for relaxing restrictions
and matthew taylor can
i go with you first of all because you
know there are
there are concerns that this may be um a
large developer politics in uh this
decision by the prime minister as well i
mean it's no it's an open secret isn't
it it's not even a secret that there are
many on his back benches that wanted to
see uh restrictions relaxed quite a long
time ago
yeah so look i think it's incredibly
important for policy and for public
trust that these decisions are seen to
be driven by the science and i would
actually
encourage the government when it makes
these announcements to be honest if
there are if there is a serious
group of people in the scientific
community who don't agree now you know
in the end yes it is about science but
you have to make a judgment and we have
as we have had throughout this crisis on
the one hand the need to protect the nhs
and public health on the other hand
people's desire to be free and the
desire of business for example the
hospitality industry to thrive so that
is a political judgment in the end
but we need to be honest with people
about the science and if the scientists
don't agree well we should be honest um
about that about that too you know the
important things we see at the moment
is this
continued decline in the number of
people in hospital and getting and very
sick and as long as that continues
then i think
the prime minister's plan is one which
people will broadly uh support
but we do need to keep an eye on this as
i said before it new variants not just
new variants it's the decline in um
immunity you know will we get to the
situation where we start to be uh
vulnerable again we need to to watch
that as well and difficult challenges in
the health service because on the one
hand
we are still suffering from high absence
rates because people are off with covid
so it'd be great to get those people
back to work even earlier but then the
last thing you want to do is to bring
people
into hospital who've got a virus passing
it on to people who are vulnerable so
that's a tricky dilemma for health
service leaders professor woolhouse pick
up on that about uh a new variant so
many people asking about that i mean
there are going to be new variants we
more or less know that for certain the
question is um how dangerous will they
be and um added to that so will it
affect our ability to detect emerging
threats from covid if we end up testing
less
well
i mean first let's put that in context
there are three drivers of the level of
infection over the next
12 months or so at least
one of them is new variants which i've
come to but the other is waning immunity
both natural immunity and the protection
the vaccines afford us so we have to
think about that and scientists are
monitoring that very closely as you
would expect and the other is people's
behavior so
we were talking about earlier about the
possibility of a resurgence when these
legal restrictions are removed that
that's not automatic that depends very
much on what people actually do
uh and my sense of this over the course
of the pandemic is people have actually
been far more conscious uh cautious or
and responsible and careful
than scientists were giving them credit
for and that's one of the reasons why we
haven't seen major researches so far as
restrictions have been lifted
the new variance is the big unknown
we can't know when the next variant will
come i'm pretty sure it will come
sometime but i can't tell you when and
nor can we know the properties that
we'll have whether it be more pathogenic
as the delta was compared with previous
variants or more transmissible as
omicron was but perhaps more mild as
well we simply can't tell that so one of
the things that has to be built into the
public health planning going forward for
the whole of the uk
is flexibility
we must have systems in place where we
can respond rapidly
if a potentially threatening new variant
does arrive the way that we actually did
respond quite rapidly when omicron
arrived and that was vital for
controlling this latest wave and we may
well have to do that again so we mustn't
assume that everything we do is
irreversible indefinitely okay that is
flexible that's interesting to hear not
irreversible and the ability then to
bring in restrictions as quickly as
possible
well the ability to change people's
behavior as quickly as possible which
doesn't necessarily rely on legal
requirements we can do that very
effectively with strong public health
advice particularly if people recognize
the need for it
okay got a direct question for you
hilary maxwell uh from lorraine lorraine
asks and you did touch upon this but
please expand what about those who are
clinically vulnerable
how does how living with covet how do
they do that
um i i think it is it is difficult it is
it is a balance of risk um
uh certainly you know in my my cancer
care practice i i certainly wouldn't
want my
patients who
time and life is very valuable to to be
living as hermit but i think it is about
balancing that risk
um and often being cautious but without
stopping living as well i think
you know without a doubt case numbers
are still quite high we can't deny that
and hospital numbers are still quite
high and sadly people are still dying
from this disease so for those people
who are clinically clinically vulnerable
this is still a huge worry we know that
chemotherapies and immunotherapies
affect the immune system and uh despite
uh you know the great strides we've made
in vaccines which is absolutely
phenomenal
those people will still be anxious and
cautious because they've spent so long
now shielding from a very difficult and
dangerous virus and i think as has been
clearly stated we we are going to get
more variants we don't know
what that's going to look like um on the
ground
um and so people will inevitably feel
nervous but i suppose what i would say
is the same that i would say to my
patients is to be cautious but to ensure
that you still go out and live your life
what about the family and friends of
those clinically vulnerable who want to
visit the matthew taylor we've
got this question from katie who says
when will the nhs be able to lift the
rules around patient visits i know you
don't run an individual hospital or
trust but uh katie has a child and so
many people in this um in this situation
katie has a child who's been going
through cancer treatment since 2020 but
only one parent is allowed to attend
treatment and it's of course been very
distressing for for them all for katie
and of course her child and all the
relatives around them
we're not at that point yet but do you
think we're going to get there fairly
soon
well i think this is the point i was
making earlier which is that
in many ways
the health service welcomes
the removal of restrictions
more than anybody in the sense that we
are suffering from
high absence rates of staff it may it's
more hot dip we heard
just yesterday about the plan for
elective recovery which is a very
demanding uh plan that's more difficult
when you've got infection control
measures in hospitals which means that
you can't use the space as flexibly as
you might want and of course
hospital leaders want patients to be
able to be visited by relatives they
want the patient experience to be as
good as possible and i think that one of
the things that was hardest for health
staff throughout the last two years has
been applying those restrictions which
mean that the patients have not been
able to be with their loved ones so
you know we want to be able to move back
to normal as as soon as possible but on
the other hand
we don't want a situation in which
infection rates rise and more people are
sick because that's going to be even
more disruptive so this is why this is a
different this is why this is a
difficult balancing act
and the other thing i want to say is
it's not just about hospitals we have
much higher rates of infection in the
community we've got very high rates of
long covered
as well so the covid phenomenon is still
out there and is still having an impact
on all parts of the health center
and i suppose that goes for social care
as well
in terms of people wanting to be able to
go into visit but of course so wanting
to be careful about their friends and
relatives who are in there we've touched
on this issue but let's concentrate on
it now about some people who do test
positive but no longer have to
self-isolate by law the prime minister
spokesperson clarified that the
government will not of course be
recommending those who test positive for
kobe go into work but where does that
leave employers and employees do you
think we'll have a spike in cases
because people with covid will go into
work and professor woolhouse
particularly if they they don't know
they have kovid because they they begin
to stop testing
well this is something that's not clear
right now is it the
introduction of self-testing seems to
have been very effective indeed in
helping us not the salt factor but
helping us control the american wave and
it's been very important for the
uh aspects that my two fellow panelists
have nicely emphasized in the last few
minutes one is protecting people who are
clinically vulnerable and also by
protecting the health care system i
would add to that the social care system
and care homes as well so i very much
hope that the end of legal restrictions
to self-isolate
does not mean an end to people testing
themselves whether it's for those
reasons or for just going to work and
the uptake of the testing has been quite
phenomenal over the last few weeks 85
percent of the population say they've
tested once at least in the last week
more than half have tested three times
and i would strongly suspect that people
who are prepared to test themselves are
also prepared to modify their behavior
should they test positive so i very much
hope that again the change in the legal
requirements here there's never been a
legal requirement to self-test and
people are doing it anyway so this will
not lead to a drastic change in behavior
across all of society protecting the
vulnerable and reducing community
transmission and i'm optimistic about
that and hillary maxwell i guess in your
area the last thing you want
is people coming in to work who've
tested positive or haven't tested but uh
have the disease
and i think i think this is of concern
because of the symptom of symptomatology
of govid that's you know some people
have likened it to a cold and
particularly as the variants have become
perhaps less intense um there is a risk
that you know as healthcare
professionals we may well go into a
hospital setting with what we think is a
cold but is actually covered
on the on the plus side what i would say
is i think healthcare professionals are
extremely responsible and um i think you
know we've tested routinely and i think
most people are perhaps now just a
little bit more aware that if they have
cold-like symptoms that they will have
on their radar that this could well be
covered and we'll do a self-test so
despite the fact that as my colleague
said there hasn't been a legal
requirement people are much more in tune
and perhaps a little bit more heightened
in their awareness that this is a
sensible step to take because the last
thing as you say you want to do is to
infect vulnerable people not least
obviously we still have high sickness
numbers has been stated in in the health
service and of course usually if a
clinician gets it they've probably got
it from their family and so on it goes
around the family you get a long-stay
absence from that clinician and that's
no good to anybody whatsoever at all and
certain certainly not the patient so i i
really hope that people will have that
heightened awareness but i think it's
very difficult to know how people will
long people will keep that heightened
awareness up or
and professor woolhouse i mean do you
think we're going to see an increase in
cases in the the wider community
in schools in those hospitality areas
well for the reasons we've been
discussing uh particularly the
willingness of people to self-test to
change their behavior i don't think
that's a given it's a clear risk and
we've already discussed the the trends
in cases and i think you mentioned at
the beginning of the piece that the
numbers of infections have increased
ever so slightly this week that's
actually mostly in school children and
has been for some time the main way
in the adult population seem to have
passed over the christmas period so i
i'm not at this stage expecting a major
rebound but there might there might be
some adjustment the key
and we've already highlighted this point
is that those cases don't translate into
hospitalizations and that does mean uh
taking precautions to prevent
transmission in environments where there
are vulnerable people
and mackie taylor got a lot to to
address then with you you've got this
issue of of staff testing positive no
longer leading needing to self-isolate
but we don't want them going into work
certainly not in in health care settings
and this issue of wider community
transition let's put that together with
what was announced by the government
yesterday uh the attempt to deal with
the huge backlogs that have built up
that are building up in people who need
care for things other than than covid i
mean it goes without saying that if
community transition goes up there will
be more coveted cases coming into
hospitals and that'll derail the backlog
plan
yeah there's no question the the
elective recovery plan yesterday was a
best case scenario we really hope that
we can deliver
on that plan but it does require things
to go our way and one of the things it
requires to go our way is that we don't
see
a big increase in the infection rate or
a variant or as professor wallhaus said
a decline in immunity leading to cases
becoming more severe so there are lots
of ways in which covid can interfere
with the plan which relies on things
going the right way
and even then we're going to see waiting
lists go up for the next couple of years
you know i think an important part of
this conversation is that the prime
minister has promised not just an
announcement
about removing legal restrictions but a
plan on how we live with kovid
and and i think you know this is the
point we're all emphasizing that we do
need to think this through you know in
other cultures countries who have for
example experienced pandemics before in
the past and
it is considered
inappropriate to go into work even with
the cold there is a sensitivity to the
idea that actually it's you know it's
it's not a good idea if you've got any
kind anything that's infectious to be
around
other people there are other countries
where wearing masks is not just
something that you do in a global
pandemic but actually it's something
that you might do more conventionally
because maybe you are concerned that
you've got a cold or you don't want to
to catch a cold so
i i and i also think that we know we've
got to ensure that we remain prepared in
case
things do go wrong we mustn't just
breathe uh sliver if we are still in a
position where
another round of this pandemic is more
likely than uh than a pen than having a
pandemic was three or four years ago we
mustn't behave as if somehow this is
passed and we can wait decades before it
rises up again so i
i also think this point about testing is
really important
it is absolutely right the that people
have have tested they wanted to test i
think that for a long time into the
future if you were having someone in
your house who had a a a a a
vulnerability you would want to test
yourself if you worked with someone like
that you'd want to test
yourself and indeed
one of the other things we heard
yesterday from the government was
the next steps in a kind of diagnostic
revolution the idea that we test
ourselves about our health is going to
become more part of our lives anyway so
one of the questions about kobe is the
habits that will last even beyond covert
and i think testing yourself and i think
thinking about how you protect other
people from any illness you might have
these are good habits that should last
that's a very very interesting point you
make and professor wallhacks you're
nodding along there so do you think that
these habits have now become ingrained
the psyche has changed the change the
government doesn't need to get involved
that the peer pressure your own internal
pressure will mean that you wear a mask
if you've got symptoms of a cold you
won't go into work and you'll test
yourself
i i think that's a a real possibility i
i mean this has been an event the last
two years on a truly historical scale
and it's going to leave long-term
effects behind of all kinds but i think
this behavioral change we've been
talking about is likely to be one of
them the only note of caution i'd add is
throughout this pandemic actually
predicting what people will do has
turned out to be rather difficult but as
i said earlier in general they've
actually been more cautious more
responsible more careful
than many people have expected so if
that continues then i think yes indeed
these behavioral changes could be long
term
and incidentally that will have some
interesting impacts because if you
recall we hadn't actually had a major
influenza
outbreak for the last two years and
there's very clear and obvious reasons
for that uh if our behavior is
sufficient to suppress covid it is
easily sufficient to suppress influenza
yeah so there may be quite a difference
to the epidemiology of respiratory
infections generally in the uk and that
will have big implications of course on
we're just really out of time i'm sorry
jumping we're nearly out of time i
really want to i'm seeing you and
nodding along there hillary just give us
your thoughts on that on the change in
people's personal behavior
i think we have seen considerable change
and i do hope that's one that will be
sustainable um i think we just have to
be respectful of each other in society
and recognize that we don't know who
we're walking by or encountering who may
be vulnerable and um we have to think
about would we want that for our own
families or relatives um and i don't
think we would so i think um and i very
much hope that those behavioral changes
will last however i know that we're not
very good at keeping new year's
resolutions but i hope that the last two
probably have been a bit of a shock well
that's a resolution we hope we all keep
it's been great talking to you all thank
you so much indeed for sharing your
experience and your expertise with us
sir hilary maxwell matthew taylor and
professor mark woolhouse and you're
watching sky news tonight coming up at
eight o'clock we'll have the latest on
that news from the prime minister that
all coveted restrictions may be gone in
england within a fortnight
[Music]
[Music]
it's eight o'clock this is